so uh
we'll talk a little bit about that we'll
do we'll do one quick segment on this
because um i published an opinion piece
in newsweek today uh the january 6
committee misrepresented me
and i'll give you the the quick gist of
the story you guys heard probably the
other day that on national television
across the board there's tim cast they
run this clip where there's people
saying like kick the door in there's
gonna be a red wedding and then in
between it's me going according to fox
news donald trump says there's gonna be
a wild protest it wasn't that you know
dull i said donald trump says there's
going to be a wild protest and i think
he's right considering what we've
already seen i think things will get
wild and i said this could be trump's
last stand he's calling on his
supporters to come to dc
they play that together
and then they try and insinuate that i'm
encouraging people to take action simply
because i'm telling people a thing that
happened
so you were just mentioning
how uh what what were you just talking
we're talking about uh
you're talking about the democrats i was
gonna make a point but i forgot what you
were oh about them funding republicans
yes exactly that was it yes democrats
are paying in one's i think in in
colorado's like 30 million dollars to
fund pro-trump candidates yep jamie
raskin i'm like why is it that he put a
clip of me because they need to create
an image of a problem
to convince people that they are the
ones who can oppose that problem it is
demagoguery it is a lie the trump
supporters who are getting massive press
it's democrats funding it so they can
then turn to to their voters and say
look look at that scary thing only we
can stop it but they're the ones paying
for it it seems a bit cynical
i wouldn't expect it out of democrats
uh it's an evil manipulative and
cult-like and and it's not gonna work i
mean it can really remember how the
entire media was uh pushing for trump
for the first time they thought they
thought great is great for tv and he'll
never win this is perfect they loved it
i mean they loved it
let me let me tell you guys something
really interesting about this uh this
op-ed and the january 6th thing i have
had friends
hit me up who had trump derangement
syndrome
being like something's not right here
like i don't understand what just
happened you're a human right i've had
well the thing is
there are people who follow this show
who don't like donald trump
and know at the very least they might
not like me but that i am not what
they're trying to claim me to be like
putting
the the january 6 episode we have was
embedded in the newsweek article and in
it it's like a whole two and a half
hours or whatever of
a conversation as to why violence
doesn't work why we've always condemned
it why this will make things worse why
it's bad and then even in the lead-up to
this in september i have a video where
i'm saying that
black lives matter lost all of their
support they gained throughout the year
by engaging in riots don't do this stuff
it doesn't work it hurts your cause and
then jamie raskin so this is really
funny by the way his office is like 30
miles from here because he reps the
district right next to us so i'm going
to go to his i'm gonna go to his office
yeah yeah i'm i'm probably tomorrow i'm
gonna go knock on the door and be like
hey guys look i'm here you guys lied
about me
so hey you should definitely do that and
definitely bring a camera closer ask for
an apology i like this idea where's uh
oh he's out getting a haircut you liar i
know you're a liar now well he might not
be at his office in maryland right but
uh it's very close i'll show up and i'll
i'll leave a note or something i'll say
hey guys look uh uh i some of my
employees are constituents
of representative raskin and he is
smearing me my company and lying for for
what i believe to be political gain but
maybe i'm wrong about him and he'll
apologize publicly for including me
incorrectly in his in his in his video
well i expect him to take the classy
move and so does my unicorn
that's right
that's right i'm i i think that the
unicorn that's puking uh rainbow glitter
his name's chad great he has a name
i have a feeling i'm capturing
and they're gonna say we don't care you
can't do anything about it we can say
whatever we want and get out i have a
feeling if i show up they're going to be
like you can't be here you need to leave
that would be interesting too why could
you not be there yeah are you because
you're going to say they're
understanding in your waiting room is it
is it wrong to do that because i was
informed by you that it's okay to come
and petition your representative for the
right it is okay should i should i hire
like a handful of people just hold signs
in front of his office saying he lied no
i think the democratic the diplomatic
approach is right and you can of course
petition the government for a redress of
grievances at least theoretically it
says it for sure well so the issue with
this uh but it also says you could keep
it bear arms
see how that's gone that's going great
yeah no in new york they are like no we
don't we're not going to follow the
supreme court and they've they're
starting out you know yeah they're
trying to say that the entire city of
new york is like some sanctuary a
sensitive area
when they when the uh
bruin opinion specifically says don't
try that trick you can't do that you
know it's really remarkable how angry
democrats get after the supreme court
says you have to stop violent
systematically violating people's rights
and then they launch into massive
resistance that's right like oh i don't
know brown versus board of education
you know wasn't it funny how they all
these people were like
there was an op-ed that's uh who was it
by i think it might have been politics
girl do you guys know who that is oh
yeah no we we've invited on the show
before but i guess they just don't want
to do it i'm not surprised and she's
like it's a podcast funded by uh midas
touch oh god but she she what happened
she made a very powerful point against
gay marriage it was kind of crazy she
said that uh something like
the supreme court should not be
legislating and deciding what is law and
what is not law and then i was like that
would rescind a lot well the supreme
court actually the supreme court sort of
said that recently with the epa ruling
right right right and they said you know
if congress wants to do this congress
has to do this right so so what's
happened is many people on the left are
trying to come up with some kind of
sophistry as to why the supreme court is
wrong so there's two things one the
supreme court should not arbitrarily
decide what the law is and then it's
like so you agree with the supreme court
that's what they said then the other the
other issue is
they're saying that if the supreme court
is going to rescind its own precedence
then they're illegitimate and it's like
now you're advocating for brownview
board of education oh and you're poor
scott
come on
the supreme court had a lot of bad
decisions we get rid of
yes it's uh look
we're not here we're not having a
rational debate here you're the the left
is going to take the position that's
most convenient to the left and it's
accumulation of power and money
every single time
yes then it's next which is why i don't
want to argue with the left i just want
to defeat them i don't and and that's
why i i never go to the left with hey
you know if uh don jr had been uh you
know of his his uh
laptop had been compromised and his uh
you know stripper antics you know the
late doing blast and rails off the butt
of a latavian hooker videos had been out
there you'd be treating it differently i
don't do that to the left because they
don't care it doesn't matter they're
immune to hypocrisy because
that's that's not what they're about
they're about power normal people though
normal people see that and go huh that's
a problem so we have to keep making the
argument but the argument needs to go to
normal people as far as the left it's
like now you just can't do that here's
what i'll do not letting you i'll take
the twerking old man with a little girl
and i'll do a a a loop where it like
plays for and then rewinds and it'll say
vote raskin and flash and then i'll hire
someone to hold that up in front of his
office oh my gosh
that's it that's it that's that's that's
terrific raskin celebrates all
identities yeah just have that down i
won't i won't tell i don't say anything
about him i'll just say vote for him
pride for for asking just hold up get
more of this we'll get a bunch of you
know those trucks with the ad tvs on oh
my gosh that would be hilarious oh
that's a really good idea actually to
get like the lights with like you don't
know
those trucks that carry billboards yeah
yeah and then just have it playing the
twerking old man and just get like
should we hire like a hundred of those
and have you drive around dc
vote jamie raskin yeah no i won't say
anything it'll just show the video
you could definitely do that it'll say
something like minneapolis pride and
just
that's it that's all it is
drive them around we'll hire what if we
did like you know i think to make it
impactful you need like a hundred of
them and just have them driving
throughout the city you gotta be careful
not to show it to kids because that
defeats the message what do you mean
there's literally a child watching it
happen and they're cheering for it
encouraging the point is how bad that
was
don't do it again
it is important that people see that
that adults see that and understand okay
no no actually that's an important
question
would they get mad ian
is there something wrong with it it was
on a public minneapolis street with
people cheering as a little girl watched
i don't see anything where's your pride
maybe i would drive it around after
hours but no no no when the parents
complain about it it's exactly the point
oh
you all have an issue with this in dc
what are you bigots
i'm literally shaking you're just
thinking about that
that why are they denying the existence
of whatever the hell uh tidy weighty boy
is tidy
non-binary whatever the hell he is
there's there's so many videos of this
of this stuff and that video i think is
like the one thing he sent to somebody
to make him be like what
i'm still trying to get over the
twerking legislator from uh rhode island
yeah yeah holy cow oh that was wild
that's pretty bad did you see watch that
on the after show that's pretty amazing
it's like nobody should see that but
you're a gynecologist all right
i'm looking it up right now oh no don't
do people are allowed to twerk i don't
care i think when i see that i'm glad
she twerked because i will not support
someone who's doing that you know mac
yeah yeah like i don't care that she
does it she's allowed to do it it's
america and i'll vote for somebody else
i don't live in rhode island so i really
don't care all that well i think you
should i do think you should mock her
and that comes back to the tolerance
thing i'm not going to say it's okay
with me it's not it's stupid and it's
gross and you shouldn't do it i'm not
going to send the cops to arrest you
uh because first of all i don't want to
get ptsd
but uh
you know don't look at me you go oh well
you know i you know you're living your
best life no you're not you're living a
terrible life and you need to stop and
you need some jesus lady this is the
thing with the abortion right i mean
this is the thing with abortion too
people say like i had an abortion and it
saved my life and it's like no you had
an abortion that saved your lifestyle
and i don't think it was really
worth saving thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there